we'll take a bunch of suggestions then
we'll drop a beat to a freestyle uh
let's come I guess this section number
one what would you like a rap about
existential dread wow that's really
[__] heavy for a Wednesday
an existential dread I love it let's
come to kind of the middle but let's
kind of go this side in the middle what
do you want to wrap that
blood flow is that what you said
blood you said blood flow
okay
[__] terrified
people over here watching like a rap
about
happiness thank you for counterbalances
someone here was just like oh
how personally said happiness what's
your age
25 that's usually usually you've got to
be a lot younger to feel the joy that
your voice resounds with
do you live in the city
you do live in the city you Super Rich
why are you so cheerful
oh you don't have okay good thank you
yeah don't feel bad now person who went
oh okay
um happiness I guess is an abstract
concept great blood flow exit yeah no no
no no don't worry lesbian weddings who
said that oh are you going to be wet
soon oh that's congratulations lovely
stuff
you better [__] clap more when I do
this rap right that's
it's not braver in New York [__] if
we were you know if we were [__] in
the South you're like you're [__]
applaud that yeah holy [__] okay
um happiness lesbian weddings
existential dread blood flow
such a weird [__] word
this section you get the final one don't
make it weird but make it good What's it
gonna be
okay well the person who said Israel
Palestine could pipe down
just being like there's a British man
it's his fault really so
he got all casual with the pencil we
were just like well this will work there
we go
you said Nigerian hair braids
Manchurian okay cool Manchurian hair
braids uh okay well this is uh this is a
wrap Let's uh do me a favor drop that
beat yeah see how excited I've sounded
about this that's because of people
sharing happiness and existential dread
blood flow lesbian weddings and
Manchurian hair braids we're gonna make
all this up it'll be as good as the
suggestions so if you don't like it it's
your fault
okay where's the B even dropping don't
pump up a little bit okay sir
okay start with over there
scratch my scalp I'm not sure where
you're from China technically Manchuria
like a candidate played by Denzel
Washington still I've got to get my hair
done I'm washing some off the base of
the follicles I'm going off to my barber
follow yours they start pulling aside
several hours it's like half a day plus
but it's in my power I say do it like
the guys from the Far East Asia the hair
texture is much lazier needs less
relaxing gotta keep it tight I've never
seen braids on an Asian guy but maybe it
would look good maybe they could rock it
walking over here lady not in the pocket
she's like no happiness no emotion need
solution from this guy bro show some
emotions shouting them out I'm feeling
sleep feeling so joyous everybody sees
me they're like oh [__] check this bro
it's probably hopped up on Lexapro
that's an antidepressant I do it never
relax and then I kick back maybe popping
some Xanax that takes the air job I sit
there in my bed thoughts in my head
feeling existential dread like I'm a
real I can't believe I'll say this are
they Faking It are we all in the Matrix
is the outside Just an Illusion are we
in the letter versus there being
collusion between philosophers and big
Tech I feel the dread right there like
the pain in my neck on my vertebrae and
people shout hooray when they see two
birds getting wet today they go it's
wonderful they're best friends look at
this wedding with lesbians and while
you're there walking down the aisle
going oh one day we'll adopt a child or
do some type of sperm donor situation
how long have you been together if I may
ask
three years that's quick but that's
usually how lesbians do it that's
probably quite long for you some people
do it even like less than two they're
like let's move in and let's share
clothes oh look at these things though
we can go but good for you I'm glad that
you're ever so happy now the guy over
there being weird when we're rapping he
says oh yeah it's being a good show but
now I'll [__] it up blood flow what the
[__] do you mean what are you like type
AAA be or oh that's right you'd be
walking around stalking the people
getting a scalpel you really like to
Sneasel and cut them a little bit and
what the blood drops blood flow here in
the hip hop ever so strange but don't
worry there's much more you see all the
red blood cells in the door what's the
little thing it's called hemoglobin by
haploid that's the shape that I'm going
did a slight little bit of biology
degree so I could break it down like a
phagocyte with Glee a phagocyte is a
white blood cell going chasing it's not
a homophobic slur that's not the places
I would do that and never forget
platelets all we need the best yet if
you are a platelet donor they're good
for you and if you've got good plasma
then put it into you might be looking
classy I'd ever so bored but the blood
flow chaff he's ever so assured he's
like this is really pure the guy you
[__] serves this blood flow makes me
so hard so turgid and that's what it is
that's the collection cause blood flow
in the dick causes massive erection
oh
[Applause]